Qué información maneja usted sobre estos
hechos se sabe cuándo y cómo desapareció
la Sargento junto a su familia Hola
Santiago Buenas noches pues un saludo a
la audiencia también en efecto Pues el
conocimiento que tenemos sobre este
hecho que se presentó a inicio de semana
el tres de Julio en el departamento de
arauca hasta hoy fue confirmado tenemos
conocimiento de que las Sargento y sus
dos hijos se estaban movilizando en un
vehículo particular desde el municipio
de fortul hacia el municipio de arauca
en este trayecto pues al parecer Fueron
interceptados por estructuras del eln y
pues hasta hoy Se confirmó efectivamente
que están siendo retenidos por ese grupo
armado ilegal a esto quería apuntar en
la siguiente pregunta por qué tanto el
gobierno como el ejército apuntan al eln
como los autores del secuestro tiene
esto que ver con los hechos de violencia
de los últimos días atribuidos a esta
guerrilla
en efecto pues se han adelantado Las
investigaciones por parte de las fuerzas
militares y el gobierno nacional bueno
los primeros
descubrimientos es que el eln fue el
presunto responsable ya que pues en esta
zona del departamento de arauca tienen
una fuerte presencia territorial a
través del frente domingo Laín que hace
parte también del frente de guerra
oriental de esa estructura armada por
supuesto Este no es un hecho aislado
también en diferentes zonas del
territorio nacional se han presentado
otro tipo de hechos que se han atribuido
al eln inclusive en el otro lado del
país y en el departamento de chocó el
frente de guerra occidental ha anunciado
que va a desarrollar un paro armado en
la región del San Juan entonces este
secuestro de las argentinas sus dos
hijos se suma otro tipo de hechos en
simultáneo durante esta semana Francisco
cree usted que con todos hechos que se
suman y que usted bien resumida se puede
ver comprometido el inicio del alto del
fuego que se esperaba para mañana 6 de
Julio con este grupo guerrillero
en efecto pues ese tipo de hechos son no
lunares que no favorecen para nada el
inicio del César fuego entre el eln y
las fuerzas militares también pues parte
de el inicio de este cese pues sería
bien acompañado en este caso de la
liberación de la Sarmiento y sus dos
hijos y también pues la suspensión de
acciones militares por parte de esta
estructura Armada ilegal contra la
fuerza pública Esperamos que del seis al
tres de agosto haya esta suspensión de
acciones y que también haya lirios
humanitarios para la población civil de
las zonas donde el eln tiene una
injerencia territorial